pour ses 50 ans isabelle décide de se
faire un cadeau
elle loue pour quatre ans la décapotable
de ses rêves mais une semaine plus tard
le concessionnaire à une mauvaise
nouvelle pour elle il ya une erreur dans
le contrat lui dit il le vendeur s'est
trompé le taux d'intérêt de l'allocation
n'est pas de 2,9 pour cent mais de 3,9
pour ça isabelle ne sait pas quoi faire
pour la durée du contrat
ces 800 $ de plus qu'elle devra payer le
concessionnaire met la pression sur elle
pour la convaincre de signer un autre
contrat
isabelle a l'impression qu'on la prend
pour une voleuse elie mortifie le cadeau
de ses 50 ans est devenu empoisonne le
concessionnaire petit l'obligé isabelle
un signe un nouveau contrat
non une fois le contrat signé le
concessionnaire doit respecter sa
signature et assumer le fin mot de
l'histoire
un contrat sur lequel on appose sa
signature c'est un engagement devant la
loi
on ne change pas de contrat comme de
jour
où